you may have seen this I know you guys
don't watch corporate media that much
God bless you so this may be the first
time you're seeing some of this over the
weekend there were massive the massive
Summer of Love 2020 like riots in
Atlanta okay antifa which is a fascist
organization it is an arm of the
Democrat Party period there is no doubt
when they want violence on the streets
they somehow get it to antifa and these
people always burn down democrat-run
cities
they're not that bright people do it
anyway antifa is basically burning down
Atlanta over the weekend it was it was
absolutely insane we're going to show
you a couple of videos of this but watch
how the media frames all of this so it
doesn't even matter why they were doing
it I'm not I'm not going to get into any
of the defensive antifa or any reason
you'll see a little something none of
that matters the point is a bunch of
masked thugs are burning down using
flash bombs burning things up breaking
windows at least now Fox 5 in Atlanta
covers these protests take a look over
here if you pan over I want to show you
this is what they were handing out at
that protest so it was a largely
peaceful protest where they just wanted
what they're calling justice uh four to
two uh for tutor do you have to tour
today so sorry
uh and right now uh you'll see basically
they want uh justice for him want
Justice for this guy that's what we're
really going to focus on they're burning
down the whole city I can't pronounce
the guy's name doesn't even matter it
literally does not matter whether
whatever happened to that guy it's
completely irrelevant if something bad
happens in society and something unjust
happens it does not give you a right to
burn down a city we all used to agree
about that sort of thing but now we
don't now if you think that was bizarre
okay now watch CNN covering this they
have a guest on in Atlanta who is some
sort of journalist in Atlanta and he
doesn't want us to use the word Violet
for the people that are violently
Burning Down The City from from the
standpoint of of the protesters
um but as as even the chief himself said
this is a small group
um this isn't this is also Within this
defend the forest movement
um there are no leaders so people go off
and do their own thing that doesn't just
make them justifiable but I do think
that you know you keep using these words
violent violent violent violent
um and it gives the impression I mean
the only violence that that or the only
acts of violence against people that I
saw were actually police tackling
protesters
hmm and you've been there you've been
how profoundly embarrassing for CNN you
know they used to say the most trusted
name in news how profoundly embarrassing
first off a small group of people can do
a whole bunch of bad stuff this thing
about small seems to be the the left's
new line on everything right Joe Biden
just had a small amount of documents
that were illegally taken okay but it's
not about the size of the amount of
documents and these it's a small amount
of people burning down the whole city if
it was a little it was a medium amount
we'd be a little more upset about it no
a whole a small amount of people can do
a real a bunch of really bad stuff also
at the end there though it's only the
police officers that are attacking
people these people were literally
smashing Windows burning buildings and a
whole bunch more absolutely ridiculous
[Music]
foreign